diese beiden wunderschönen boliden
kosten knapp drei millionen euro und wir
sind heute mit denen auf der rennstrecke
ich hoffe das geht gut und damit
herzlich willkommen zu auto bild das
magazin ich bin euer sydney und diese
weiteren themen haben wir noch am start
der ford focus im dauertest wie gut ist
er nach 100.000 km in schuss wir
zerlegen ihnen komplett
bisher hat der dauertest und überhaupt
keine probleme dargestellt für den fokus
aber jetzt zerlegen in den motor zu
legen das getriebe schauen die mama
genau und das blechkleid finden wir
irgend eine schwäche bisher nämlich sind
wenig geleistet
und 600 sie macht sich ps im elektroauto
wir laden im amg
53 mal ordentlich durch
gedreht jetzt bei 65 einfach drauf und
ja also
selbst wenn man sich vornimmt man kann
den kopf halten es geht so loos und
eines der kultigsten film autos aller
zeiten der delorean dmc-12 auto zurück
in die zukunft wie fit ist er heute
also insgesamt kann man sehr sehr lässig
in diesem auto sitzen und kilometer
zurücklegen fünften gang erlegen rollen
lassen da vorne mit irgendwas
verarbeitung war ja nicht die große
stärke von die loggien und
los geht mit diesen supersportlern aus
zwei generationen einmal dem porsche
carrera gt auf 2003
und den porsche 918 spyder aus 2013
ich meine wir sind beide super selten
sie fahren über 330 km h und das nunmehr
als auf den strecken mit den fans
[Musik]